So, the idea is to put theory and practice together in the design cycle. Theory
is good for expressing abstract specifications of
the system at the level of individual components.
For this part of the design cycle,
namely specification of what we want to build.
A theoretical framework called IO automator is used
and it's syntax is very similar to C
like syntax. So, in terms of writing the specification, it's very intuitive
in how we go about using IO automator to develop the system requirements and
specify them using the syntax provided
by our automator. And more importantly, the
composition operator that's available in IO
automator allows expressing specification of an entire
subsystem that we want to build. Example, if you want to build a TCPIP protocol
stack, then all of the functional relationship
between the components of the subsystem can
be expressed using the powerful specification language,
primitives, available in IO automator. The second
part of the design cycle is converting the specification in IO automator to code
that can be actually executed. And for
this purpose, the programming language that is used
is a high level programming language called
OCaml. Stands for object oriented categorical abstract machine
language, and it has several properties that
make OCaml a very good candidate for doing
component based design as we are proposing to
do in this lesson. Number one, the formal
semantics that is available in OCaml is
a nice compliment to the specification that we've
done using IO automator. That's number one
reason why OCaml is a good vehicle for
converting the specification into code. The second
nice property that it has is it's object
oriented. Being an object-oriented language, it has
some very nice properties such as no side-effects
for things that you do in the program.
And in fact, this comes from the fact that
OCaml is a functional programming language, so some
of the properties of the functional programming language, including
no side effects and so on, make this
an appropriate vehicle to convert the specification into code.
And third, perhaps the most important characteristic from an
operating system designer's point of view, is that the
code that you can generate with OCaml is
as efficient as C code. This is super important
when you're developing operating systems. Because you care about
performance. Object oriented is good. Formal semantics is good.
But you also want to know that you get
good performance out of it. And yes, you can
get pretty good performance out of OCaml. Because, the
object code that we can generate from the OCaml
compiler is very efficient, similar to C. All
of these make OCaml a good vehicle for
going from specification to actual code. At this
point, what we have is an unoptimized code that
faithfully implements the specification that we started out
with. And remember that we are doing component-based
design, so it's going to be highly unoptimized
because there is a lot of craft that goes
between these components that you put together, like
level blocks. So we have to optimize it
before it is ready for prime time. Now,
how do we do that? Well, once again, return
to theory. NuPrl is a theoretical framework for optimization of
OCaml code. The input to this framework is the OCaml code and the
output that you get is an optimized version of a functionally
equivalent OCaml code. So that's what this optimization
framework gives you, takes the input, unoptimized OCaml code
and produces optimized Ocaml code. And the optimized
OCaml code can be theoretically verified to be functionally
equivalent to the unoptimized input OCaml code. That's
the beauty of this theoretical framework. And the way
it does that is a little bit beyond
the scope of this course. It uses a theorem-proving
framework in order to do this and verify through theorem proving that
the resulting code that is generated is equivalent to the input
code which is unoptimized. I've given you the big picture of
the design cycle, now it is time to go into the weeds